gets it away  beverly sneaks in to come back up with  the basketball and save the possession  that's what ends up winning the hearts  and minds of every fan of this building  and watching on tv  and then how about pepe knocking the  ball free again  edwards  gets the foul in transition and ant's  gonna go to the free-throw line  how do you get the  edwards all the way reverse lamp and he  gets fouled  [Music]  oh patrick beverly the lakers force a  bad shot or a shot just to beat the  buzzer but there's beverly to sneak in  and  get the bones core now beverly working  the crowd  and they are responding  to him  and look at that  he's over with lebron he's yelling right  lebron's face  and we've mentioned it before those two  hurt each other and competed